how can young people take part in EU
democracy you can engage with the
European Parliament in lots of ways
starting with together. euu a community
standing up for democracy that connects
people from across Europe meet up share
knowledge and get out the vote for
elections the I or european Youth Event
lets young people experts and decision
makers exchange views and Inspire each
other get to grips with the Democratic
process
and enjoy a hands-on experience of
European parliamentary democracy in the
Ambassador school and eurosolar programs
or step into an mep's shoes with
parliament's virtual roleplay game got a
plan for the future of the EU join the
conversation at youth
ideas. check out the youth hub for more
opportunities follow us on social media
or visit our offices across the
EU